yo Millie's is here man welcome sir my
boy yeah I'm looking forward to uh a
potential NBA Finals matchup between
your Celtics and my Phoenix Suns if KD
is healthy I love that I love to go in
there get that sweep and just celebrate
and call you after it's a sweet huh no I
don't know you know four to one or
something like that we'll overdue for a
title though
I don't think so I think you guys have
enough titles to last you you know who's
overdue for a title the Phoenix Suns you
know how many we have how many zero
no you gotta stay that way for a while
because like Jason Tatum gotta have his
run you know he's having to run Haven
Brown they gotta have that right yeah
anyway I'll be seeing you [__]
courtside at all the Celtics games yeah
what do those tickets run you oh okay
how does that work
it's like you just got to be like really
iconic and influential in the city of
Boston and then to hold you down it'd be
crazy for them to not give you free
tickets right yeah I don't want to talk
about it too much though you know
because it's like because you don't want
to like let them think I pay ten
thousand to pay ten thousand a pop so
you're getting free tickets Courtside
that's that's amazing is that through a
player through the pr or somebody at the
Celtics organization they just know
what's up they're like we got to tap in
with the hottest rapper now honestly
like that's that's
um one of the greatest things that's
ever happened to me in my career as far
as like
you know it's dope selling out shows and
all of that [__] and you know everything
that comes with rap but I used to get
hyped when people would give me a
t-shirt right so to give me courtside
Celtics tickets to the finals
well you got it because I rap for three
finals tickets and yeah come on stop wow
and like I really sat there me pissed
and kiss watching the Celtics with the
Warriors ass if I if I had came back
like if I had been in another game we
would have won again bro and I got a
Immaculate Courtside record I think
that's why they let me back like that
because they're like you're kind of like
the actual like leprechaun I am lucky
yeah yeah for sure you know they should
have flew you out to the Bay for those
freaking Warriors yeah they should we
would have won for sure it's something
about the energy you know but yeah
that's like one of the biggest
accomplishments of my life like thank my
plugs so much and just thank the
organization they treat me amazing yeah
I remember last year I sat Courtside for
the first time
at a Sons game and I was like oh this is
like a dream come true and you sat in
the balcony right yeah I mean I sat
everywhere but I never sat Courtside
until last year and I was like this is
insane nah it is different it's just
like you know I'm a are you like a
die-hard basketball fan I'm Gonna Die
Hard Celtics fan yeah so growing up like
can you imagine a Celtics fan and you
gotta understand like I really know the
experience like I'm from I'm from two
train stops away so we would get on the
green line and take it to leech mayor
and watch Ron Mercer yeah
crazy all that Antoine Walker Antoine
Walker yeah man
shout out to Antoine that was the the
shots of the Celtics fan I remember
watching Antoine Walker as a kid then he
went to the Timberwolves and kind of
flanked out but you know what was great
about the Antoine Walker Jersey is when
uh what's his name the other Walker came
to December walk Campbell came it was
the same number same last name so you
could bust out the OG Antoine Walker
Jersey it's the same thing it's fire so
it was a that was like a short-lived
moment but kind of a travesty that
Antoine Walker's Jersey isn't retired
because he kind of was like the best
player on the Celtics for at least three
or four years oh yeah yeah he made the
All-Star team hell yeah I think he made
the All-Star The Walker wiggle you
remember the Walker wiggle no I just
remember you do this one hmm